Jack where are you I'm over here I'm
looking at MPC looks like it's a draw
their pickup got shot ask me shut up
okay nobody I like shooting a big joint
aracite come on hit me boy we all know
your skills with a gun Oh advice bones
that I forgot you oh my god okay Rocket
Man
what the [ __ ] okay that's gonna be a
rocket that's a perfect okay well I
guess we all what the [ __ ] is happening
all I can hear is destruction
[Laughter]
there was okay first of all we need
three shares everyone select yes that's
right we need Cheers
Telluride oh sorry this is my chair Oh
mr. luxury I know well maybe if I just
do this mouse and I we say what do you
have clients okay oh you both want to be
the chair not gonna work you all right
whatever this is what's gonna happen
tell me where there's my seat this is
gonna work cuz you froze him in place
they need to actually be welded why do I
got to do all the work here I'm just
gonna sit here and you guys do what you
want
uh-huh yeah
there's a way to unfreeze objects
[Music]
you can't even know you're not sorry I
could be can we get a road rotary oh
that's our helicopter rotor oh my gosh
[Laughter]
get rid of your thing okay okay so
that's the rotor so wait no I have an
idea this might actually work
crazily enough I'm gonna put this up
here
and then uh-huh got it if this actually
works and if you put it like a dynamite
there or something not a dynamite yeah
yeah no no I'm totally with it okay yeah
you got it's gonna work this is gonna
work this needs to be frozen in place so
we can work that is yeah and now I can
bring this over
those are soda cans how will the other
edge mark just hang on it might be the
play okay fiction right there how'd that
go fan fiction him and his welding him
and his rod I'm gonna weld my rod it
doesn't matter
believe in him oh whoops that was wrong
Sorry Sorry Sorry
god damn it welder
I just gotta weld up these last things
okay give me well well this year please
yes oh well in there one second it's you
guys just touch it with your beam I'll
unfreeze everything don't worry you'll
have a fun ride and you'll go home you
ready for the test run yes see the first
helicopter fly me to the gmod there we
go anyway countdown three two one go
I forgot that freeze things hang on now
you're on fire nah nah worry about I got
I am doing it here next Jack okay you're
just a big error symbol to me yeah we're
both woody trust us we're woody I
longing me into your or okay countdown
to 10 from 10 hang on wait no no no I'm
not even
get in that way cheers so fire I need
decoration okay you need dicks chrome
decorate Diggs okay decoration in cave a
crow that mean ice crow oh Jesus dude
what if we put a car on top of it what
are you doing not good I'm going to
shake that's not good
I don't know what you see but that's
okay I got this okay bigger rotor yeah
that was the problem
yeah not even close I'm taking this and
I'm just taking the audio of this taking
way out of context okay stick it right
there stop hold it hold it hold hold
hold hold
I'm trying okay there we go okay no it's
good no no it's good so just yeah see we
got it okay that okay okay I'll do yeah
so taking that just as audio perfect
thanks guys
does it lead to heavy petting yeah of
course
okay good okay okay
no no no okay hold it right there hold
it there I'm gonna weld it keep holding
it and weld it gonna weld it well it
well it's welded okay it's welded crap
that one's frozen pan don't there we go
okay okay okay it's not really stable
there no no that's okay I need some
weight
we obviously need another car the other
scientists okay yeah yeah hold that
night okay
that's welded up night wait no that's
wrong right there right right right yeah
just like that okay now those are stuck
now if you lift the top one okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah then I'll weld that
together okay well do you lis well d and
it's stable good it's stable I need some
really powerful butters it's gonna work
it's okay I'm gonna put the biggest
motors lightning that's pretty heavy
that's pretty Oh break it again please
yeah don't break it Jack just just just
sit well okay fine I'll use a lighter
you guys suck it looks like boobs thank
you
I know this this chair this ah that's my
aim a jack boy ready ready to fly this
is where Han goes to space okay well I
think we need more power
I'm pretty amazing it actually is fun
yeah I'm actually quite racked yeah you
said you were professional I am I was an
engineer genitive you got I were I was
biomechanical all right it's ready to go
I'm gonna wait we need to decorate in
the next time you decorated it this is
what you deserve
okay let's not decorate it then yeah
because we have an ugly helicopter oh
okay no look out gently okay I have a
new idea I don't think the car is a good
idea
Oh was that your idea cuz I think they
look pretty good
okay to you guys but I think the
decoration if the reason why I didn't
work
get back here Sally sue come over here
it's really stuck now swing side and
sling each other we could how do we I
like that idea
the chair does not go on the side deck I
don't know Ireland okay so we put it
here and then we attach you to something
that bends well bends be
so how in the world is this a Dumbo okay
lift I lift a lot of stuff yeah I don't
know where you're going with this yeah
what are we trying to accomplish
oh oh I got it well that's actually
really smart
I don't earring okay one two three like
going time you douche
okay I'm getting in I'll show you how
it's really done wait even you did I
knew I shouldn't Joey I'm trying it's
hard well I go into third-person mode
okay Wow all right you ready ready go
all right let's try this one I'll be
ready oh it didn't work
what a distance yeah I'm not really
inside you but that's fine I mean I
Rania was never really inside the cube
mark I was like right here's what's good
what is life okay my time yeah okay I
don't know how to do this so I'm gonna
just guess I'll get it I'll get it and
if I all need to weld it cuz only done
do it so oh yeah okay you got one weld
it's in the chair okay
oh I win this one I will give you
beautiful wet kiss I'd rather not can
you just give me cash or something or
like I'm some gift card already
whoa whoa we should build a baby mobile
yeah yeah like that
so just well the leaves together okay
got it boss
let's just take two babies sorry three
babies for charity babies one for each
of us yeah no I was gonna get two but
okay I guess I can compensate so three
babies yeah
holding the babies together all right
now what do we do with it um well that's
horrifying
baby care these big pimping wheels on
these big pimping babies oh well we'll
put sure on the wheels
I didn't do that
we lon well I'm gonna put big pimping
wheel on that's not good is it
Robin no one's gonna be there because
it's not welded right you dingus
thankful anything good sorry use that
word make this go that is it this far
there should be a button a button has to
that's the button to make them go
numpad 8 and precedent Oh God why'd you
know jack was we're trying to do so yeah
I had an idea
yeah okay wait no you knew your baby
thing I'm gonna I'm gonna experiment
over here
I hold eight and we get some speed going
what's it mean with that [ __ ] around
the corner I even saw you in the sofa hi
baby the words yeah wheels exactly
whoosh I just I just hiked wheel oh can
I get on this car you added chair
probably put thrusters on the boom no
don't put wheels on my thing it's a
helicopter
okay thank you this is pretty amazing
work why don't we do this before but can
we trace it into a helicopter yeah
that's what I was trying to do when you
put wheels on it I'm trying to make a
helicopter
okay put yes oh no no it's it's it's
gonna be fine those are just for
stability okay and then we put chairs on
it and then she was that Joisey axe wait
we need to be have with this theme
cheese other way we turn we ask me cry
in the last video and so it continues
okay so it should all be good it's been
done cuz I will make it spin with my own
and make it rocket at the same time oh
oh my god I'm clicking everything okay
all right well [ __ ] oh I'm clicking
everything
there was a way to move it I'm off
alright okay well this didn't work do it
thrusters didn't go
okay to everybody that okay my life
sorry we gonna do a thumbnail pretty
beautiful picture first let me take a
thumbnail don't worry we're gonna pump
it up a little bit here yeah okay I'm
ready my arms in the air do it
okay here we go what's out what's that
for use rocket incoming wait what the
hell [ __ ] working
okay everybody brofist huh all right
what how do your fingers weapons and
then others weapons and others you're
just an error to me I don't see
high-five to harbor giant boobs was the
system champion right
[Music]